welcome to this video I am volume and D
well what is this guy volume Zaitsev
yeah many zaitsev surround t5 this is a
real simply because it's believed to be
not particularly good i have d 4 or
let's what what else is if or move but
then you can probably play in gambit
style we see 6 me4 Knight takes Queen a
FOIA this is why if I as possible at all
but maybe c6 is a decent enough gambit
so I just I just go here Knight takes
Knight f3 sm the prescribed way you too
to combat this usually coming from a
Queens gambit it even has named the
Marshall defense to the Queens gambit
and it's not not very good Marshall
Marshall line there are some other
marshal lines the marshal attack in the
in the ruin the most famous one and
enter and and really a good opening that
was introduced by the American um yeah
mossy grandmas are not an official one I
guess they all need to use this later
but the American player Frank Marshall
he also was the namesake for the
Marshall gambit in the semi Slav
triangle also quite a good line came the
issue for black here in this in this
particular opening is it is just like a
goon fault but without the exchange on
c3 and why just enjoys a comfortable
space advantage him like he does not
really have a great compensation for
this
okay is he going to play f5 hmm it's not
impossible
queen bee three and maybe as queen bee
three sir potentially useful anyway and
it prevents a five why not ok it's not
preparing this maybe he wants to just
get the night over to d6 yeah thats
that's a positional idea often often
worth considering ok so he's preparing
f5 in this in this of this manner still
yeah maybe a form a4a five is
interesting here if he prevents it with
a five himself look I'm sorry he had to
weaken the Queen side ok so he's really
just not carrying much about this so I'm
going to push no ok I think him I don't
think taking only for does make any
sense so wow really
I'm a bit shocked because it gives up
the center of attention here and I don't
see a big attacker coming so okay just
go here how to play that now might be
five there is maybe 94 but that's not
really dangerous right okay I go I go
for that just a tech here this is very
much like a strange type of Kings Indian
and time is of the essence I should he
should should play a should play this
ovens on the queenside quickly I'm now
threatening to take on c6 with the
bishop and then night c7 okay what what
am I talking about him he's just not
reacting to it at all 9726 bishop d6 wat
the thread anyway so a six is basically
a loss of tempo and then 96 is what I
thought can also take and take be seven
but this this must be right come on
it simply must be right then 96 year
come on this is just just good needs to
take and then he's in this e seven
discovery directly so um okay yeah I
need to get the night into the game
night queen d 5 is this a simple
solution maybe then taking 95 I don't
really think if he goes rook the eighth
i think i can just take you five a night
discovery i play 97 and there is nothing
happening reading
okay I think if I was just dropping look
the eight looks like the relatively best
choice but i think i can just take you
five
yeah a six in particular was was really
strange okay yeah of course he wants to
take here I can I can just play an end
game with Bishop c4 which isn't bad
really
I've assistance in fact quite nice let's
do this Knight takes rook takes Queen e
six days look c 8 which is which is
really cute and this wins on the spot
but the cross pin I know Queen D Phi if
you can play Queen d5 it's not winning
okay i have this end game which is very
nice check take time Barney know the
chef first on drugs is 795 even better
narvik c7 is good
for taking off this bishop t6 em i but i
have i have not see for ochem to check
out 94
yeah this should have been over a long
time ago so this is really if I was her
I was simply check counting on this this
group Kerchak c8 move and did it did not
really work Wow amazing I really totally
spot this
jammed is probably a new bra our third
game drown yeah he he clicked it with
absolutely note i want the clock yeah
okay this is really just dead but i mean
i already knew I need to print the break
I believe if you look at this I was
thinking rook c8 wins and you can just
take here and no use really of this move
and of course the only it only makes
sense to play Bishop c4 in connection
with that and mean i can't play this and
what's what then like it's just just
giving up now I just thought that Bishop
c4 would win technically can here's no
move for this night is the problem can
play something like that but i can i can
just take it him yeah the weirdest thing
was I mean besides the strange opening
was that he played this and then a six
which is really really funny again this
is of course just just a total win i
mean yeah i just checked china this is
very good but check why did I play play
this one this is not make any sense why
not go here there's still excellent for
what can activate the king yeah I
suppose I was some really irritated why
this was still on this game yeah we had
really okay thanks for watching